thank you guys we are here with the
current leader of the tournament young
alireza feud rusja you just equalized
against the world champion it seemed
like you had absolutely no problems
yes um this opening is pretty new the
knight c6 move he it came as a surprise
to him so
he played very quickly rogue d1 which is
i think not the best move for playing
playing for advantage so
um yeah there are other better moves but
he played rook d1 very
okay not very quickly after two minutes
sinking but yeah then
i think his own
draw so
maybe i was better a little after
he wanted to bail out of course here
because he has no winning chances but
yeah maybe after bishop f3 i could play
more accurately i think the commentators
were looking at 93 or 93 in this
position instead of h6 but did you know
up to this point did you seem very
comfortable in it yes i knew that rook
devon is not accurate
but i didn't remember but okay i
calculated and it was pretty easy
the commentators in the studio were
wondering if magnus is losing a little
bit of motivation a couple of white
games he didn't produce very much easy
draw for you here what do you think
yes it's a very tough it's very tough
these days to come up with advantage for
instance the games that i won also it's
pretty dry and my opponents went very
wrong but you had this cool idea against
sarge h3 i hadn't never seen it in the
sicilian all these years of chess but
you brought it in how do you come up
with this kind of things yes it's a it's
a new thing
it's very interesting
but yeah he played very good actually
and it was very drying so
in general these days this void getting
some playable position is very difficult
even though it's difficult you are the
current leader what's making you
uh
get ahead of the game compared to your
rivals here so far
um maybe i had better pairings for
instance um than
magnus or maxime um so that could help
but also i am in
i feel like i'm playing very fast and
very good so it's good at least oh you
seem to be in great shape but there's a
very long tournament so we'll let you
rest a little bit before the next games
guys the current leader of the
tournament alireza firuja let's go back
to the city we have four more games left
thank you very much
there i i like what he was saying like